propiamente shireen abu a que no era una
figura de estado pero como reportera si
la consideraban generaciones de
palestinos y su funeral y entierro han
sido unos de los más largos y
multitudinarios tras el acto de estado
en ramala hoy miles de personas
acompañaron su féretro durante seis
kilómetros en jerusalén este desde un
hospital en chicharra hasta la ciudad
vieja allí como palestina cristiana se
le celebró una misa en la iglesia
greco-católica y sus restos fueron
llevados al cementerio del monte sión
junto a la tumba de sus padres pero
lejos de ser una tranquila procesión
ésta estuvo marcada por golpes y
lanzamientos de granadas aturdidoras de
la policía israelí la carga más grave
fue contra el cortejo que casi hace caer
el ataúd además las fuerzas israelíes
establecieron barricadas sobrevolaron
con helicópteros según testigos
intentaron evitar la entrada a fieles
musulmanes e incautaron banderas
palestinas aunque no lograron impedir
que muchos ondearán en la ciudad vieja
en una imagen poco habitual de antemano
la policía había interrogado y advertido
al hermano de agua que su intención de
intervenir en el funeral si las cosas
salían fuera
pero esto no ocurrió más allá de algunos
arrestos mientras tanto la investigación
sobre el asesinato de la periodista de
al yazira prosigue sin resultados un
informe inicial de las fuerzas israelíes
valoró que no es posible saber el origen
del disparo y planteó dos escenarios o
porque fuera alcanzada por balaceras de
milicias palestinas o por un soldado
israelí que devolvía el ataque ninguno
de estos escenarios coincide con el
relato de colegas en el lugar que desde
su muerte insisten en que en ese
instante no había intercambio de
disparos ni presencia palestina justo
allí ann jennings se reanudaron hoy las
redadas israelíes y en enfrentamientos
con las milicias murió en comandante de
la policía